transformer l'eau en vin certains ont
essayé la loi elle l'a fait et oui les
premiers cépages dans la région sont
arrivés par bateau il y apportant
longtemps à l'époque romane quoi depuis
des vignes il y en a de la touraine
jusqu'au giennois en passant plus au sud
par le berry les goûts et les couleurs
marseille discute chez nous dans le nord
on fait plutôt du rouge et dans le sud
eh ben c'est blanc le blanc on aime ça
plus de la moitié de la production c'est
du vin blanc un quart du rouge sans
oublier le rosé bien frais et nos
petites bulles régionales d'ailleurs
nous sommes la première région
d'appellation de 20 de fines bulles
champagne alors ouvrez avec 95% des
vignes en appellation d'origine protégée
sans fait les bouteilles à boire bien
sûr avec modération c'est mieux